AND THAT MAN'S NAME IS MIKE
MCDAVID WITH 110 POINTS AND
LEON DRAISAITL SUDDENLY FOURTH
IN THE LEAGUE IN SCORING.
GAUDREAU'S THSKATES HE FINDS KO
THAT MIDDLE.
AND THE FINISH AFTERWARDS JUST.
WEDGEWOOD CAREFULLY STEERED
RECTED INTO
A CROWD!
QUICK SHOT,A PHYSICAL PLAY IN
ZONE.
BOOM FINISHES HIS CHECK.
RYAN FIN
OF GAMES.
AND THAT'S WHAT IT ALLOWS JAY
WOODCROFT TO DO?OWER PLAY
THIS YEAR RANKED THIRD IN THE
LEAGUE LED BY
GURIANOV AND A SHOT SAVE SMITH
HE'LL HAVE TO FALL BACK  MIKE
OUTSTANDING ON THAT PENALTY
KILL.
GREAT PLAY.
I'M NOT SURE IF THIS RIDES UP .
UNSELFISHLY GAVE IT UP TOND CL.
PAVELSKI NUDGED OUT IN
OUT THERE.
ROOPE HINTZ
REBOUND I
OUTSIDE.
CYCLES OFF OF KEEPING
THE STARS ALIVE AT 3-2 THE.
MCDAVID TO ZOZO TUCK IT HOME.
HEISKANEN WILL KEEP AN EYE ON
IT.BLOCKED.
GREAT REACTION SAVE.GO.
WE'VE SEEN A BUNCH OF THOSEEMP.
DIDN'T GET THAT HIGH QUALITY